what if you just jerk the tree off and
then
put the semen the tree semen yeah in the
soil
[Music]
Bart knows I love science
okay how does everybody feel about life
on Mars Mars oh honey bunny you should
mention I love it I'm there all the time
Earth creature
creature I've heard that in a minute
dude of course Marvin the Martian okay
you know you know yeah he was one of my
favorites I think he's gonna [ __ ]
suck my phone is gonna suck [ __ ] yeah
dude they don't got in and out for a
while yeah this could be tough
I need in and out I need cream barbecue
and then I need some shorts weather here
and there okay do they go done you're
probably gonna have some shorts weather
out there potentially there's no ocean
no there's no so it's just like a big
Las Vegas before the casinos came like
the Red Rock Casino without the casino
just becomes Vegas please read that
headline because it's crazy
how about you do it in your Mars The
Martian okay here we go uh this is from
the Mirror by the way a very reliable
new source Life on Mars hopes as a
machine produces oxygen on the red
planet for the very first time whoa so
wait so it produced oxygen that stayed
or concentrated to one area so it's not
so much about let me let me show you a
photo so you even understand did they
shoot like an oxygen maker there and
it's just sitting there going no it's
it's a machine and it's that size this
little gold box that can turn carbon
dioxide into oxygen now obviously Mars
has a [ __ ] plethora of carbon dioxide
like nothing but it almost isn't that
the same [ __ ] as a plant though as a
tree absolutely just put [ __ ]
plants on that [ __ ] well there's also
like not really just red ready water
available so you can't just like keep
the plant alive sunlight and then also
temperatures the way that plants work on
Earth they like work within certain
tropical temperatures and stuff Mars has
much more variance much more extremities
on their surface right but what if you
just what if you just jerk the tree off
and then
put the semen the tree semen yeah in the
soil yeah Anthony yeah why not okay so
scientists say oxygen has been produced
on Mars for the first time bringing
humans closer to the possibility of Life
on another planet using an instrument
the size of a lunchbox a team sported by
NASA says transforming the red planet's
carbon dioxide to produce more oxygen
for the past 18 months wow that long
already it's a temporarily sustained
human life we're pretty sure that entire
time has been more so like trials and
stuff as well since landing on Mars in
February 2021 the MIT LED this is called
Mars oxygen Institute resource
utilization experiment or Moxie we'll
just call it Oh I thought it was going
to be moisture
that would be fun uh has turned CO2 into
oxygen at the rate of a small tree on
seven occasions because they had to test
in like a lot of varying atmospheric
like kind of situations on Mars way more
crazy over there oxygen was created both
during the day and the night in
different seasons so they needed enough
time to actually understand whether or
not the same type of like device would
be able to be used during different
times they're using their Noggin they're
using their Noggin it means that
astronauts stepping onto Martian
territory will be able to breathe
unaided for their arrival as well so
they could take off their [ __ ]
Fishbowl they can like take it off and
then breathe I think if they're in
another contained thing I don't think
the entire atmosphere at this time okay
it's time it's just especially the size
of a little boss I don't think that
little Boston to the whole planet It's
gotta be like a little burning man tent
yeah
Sandy Cheeks on SpongeBob
in a bubble with her both yeah
so I mean obviously there's still like a
million more steps to take before we can
get into any inhabitable element but
they consider this a pretty promising
and large kind of development for where
we need to go because oxygen is a huge
huge thing we kind of come yeah
um they said that we have learned a
tremendous amount that will inform
future systems at a larger scale so I
mean in essence you are right living
there right now would suck balls but
everything needed to develop a habitable
type of situation means that this this
generation this time however long it's
going to take I thought we were trying
to terraform that whole planet like
we're trying to like I mean in essence
this is a part of the terraform right to
be able to actually change the
atmosphere as well I wonder if their
origin story is going to be like at
first we had oxygen
NASA gods made oxygen
second day
they may water well when did Genesis
first be like the creation of Mars on
like a holy uh you know I'm just gonna
play with your exam well they might they
go like first they brought a gold box
yeah
no no no the first would be like first
Our God Elon scent yeah you know Elon
God
it sounds like a god name right it's
[ __ ] up on the blue place first
yeah yeah they said um quote this is the
first demonstration of actually using
resources on the surface of another
planetary body and transforming them
chemically into something that would be
useful for a human Mission it's historic
in that sense the atmosphere of Mars is
far more variable than Earth the density
of the air can vary by a factor of two
through the year I don't know what the
[ __ ] that means and the temperature can
vary by 100 degrees whoa one objective
is to show we can run in all seasons are
you guys pioneering enough to go I'ma go
out there do something dude props to the
first gen people are gonna colonize it's
gonna need to be something really crazy
and extreme for me to go there it's like
maybe like I [ __ ] up super crazy on
this planet and then like the mob is
going to kill my whole family if I don't
sacrifice myself and go on the mission
or some [ __ ] so this is the movie right
that we're gonna make it's the the first
song Gerard Butler
yeah I was listening to a podcast that
Elon was talking on and all this stuff
he was talking about the oxygen the
carbon dioxide and stuff and it's like
very possible and very serious he was
saying there will be test groups and
volunteers that people don't want to go
out there did you do it he said it's it
is gonna like the first people that go
it's gonna suck like you're on this rock
you're only gonna have a small area but
they said they will slowly bring
volunteers over to try to create this it
could fail like there's so many possible
things I feel like the same thing that
you said the people that do go like you
know people are not coming back those
people that are depressed are terrible
lives or homeless you know how I saw
your episode about the homeless hotels
we just send them to Mars
you might be paraphrasing in a way that
makes it sound really bad
the plot for Conair too yeah it's kind
of like America part three or two yeah
gonna bring all the the bad people
optimistic people yeah because if we
said the depressed ass people man just
please book it sucks I remember
um [ __ ] what movie was it was it
Interstellar yeah I'll [ __ ] love
Interstellar right yeah and then Matt
Damon's supposed to be this like revered
and glorified lie he was like the one
who would lead the bravest men and women
to go check out these he was a [ __ ] and
he ended up being the guy when he like
all hope was lost put in the the long
sleep but sent out the signal to say his
plan was habitable even though he was
lying because he need help yeah he just
want to save himself right so it's kind
of like there's that innate like maybe
you are the bravest in that moment you
don't know until you're there man yeah
and then once you get out there and the
world's or your world sucks for like 15
years and you start to go Cycles that's
why the first test group they need to
send them and they need to uh not know
they need to not know it's just a
simulation and then watch them think
it's Mars and see what they do
and then at the end of it when they're
successful go all right now you can
really go yeah and then that's when they
go cycle because they're like you've
been lying to us the whole time but
America and Australia worked out it's
kind of the same concept
well
well they already we already have things
like um plants and oxygen and yeah so I
feel like the things that they have to
deal with are just a different
Foundation of tragedy at least they
don't have to deal with Predator animals
and different tribes
you got a point there different stuff
you don't know
well maybe that there might be uh Marvin
the Martians out there that are like
dude they might have some Martian ground
Gophers that [ __ ] dig out from the
bottom all of a sudden eat your ass
they'll have Martian Thanksgiving now
though
woke up with the golfers there you're
gonna have Martian Thanksgiving they're
going to have a whole different kind of
it's gonna be gonna be like go for
genocide first though right and then
we'll do holidays for a while because
we're gonna wipe them out whatever's
there right I feel like with a gun
called The Santa Maria isn't this what
England did like they just kept sending
like I mean our jails are packed let's
just [ __ ] send our [ __ ] homeless
and crazy people let's just send them
different different places right and
then all the countries did really really
good
so maybe Mars would do really really
good we just need they also did turn
their back on them so what if we send
these new guys to Mars they turn their
back on us they attack us oh and they're
like how are we going to listen to a
tyrant ruler more than 3 000 miles away
they're gonna have their own July 4th
yeah and they'll have Martian fireworks
saying Independence Day yeah I never
think about that they have their like
marshes to this movie The Martian tea
party and [ __ ] like that the Martian tea
party yeah whatever rebel against us
damn I never thought about that dude and
now that you know anything different in
the way you're gonna live your life I
I'm staying in ice I like Earth
foreign